it's this a service where we'll be
working with all the partners around the
area including the the two life-saving
clubs which will have a very close
relationship with will also be working
with the other arm ly assets the
lifeboat station in exmouth and also
here in timnath and it'll be a very
close relationship the improvements that
you're going to see will be things like
new equipment in the first couple of
years the new equipment that will be
introducing you'll see an atv an
all-terrain vehicle bike here at timnath
which will be used to toe and to launch
the rescue watercraft a rescue
watercraft is very similar to a jet ski
but with a pure rescue capacity they'll
have a sled on the back operated by a
lifeguard for very quick kind of dash
and grab rescues if you like we're not
going to be out there rescuing boats or
towing people in and towing yachts and
things like that but we're out there to
help bathers and to help people that are
using the water of course the lifeboat
service is always there for the rest of
it now that we've officially launched
the service you're actually going to
start to see a little bit of activity
around the beach you'll start to see
some training who will actually be
starting the life guarding the side of
things as of the Whitsun bank holiday
you'll see lifeguards and then
patrolling weekends only from 10 till
six up until the fourth of July and then
they'll be working full time for you to
the sector September there's going to be
two lifeguards either side of the pier
here in Timoth and also another two
lifeguards down in dawlish Warren and
we'll pick those numbers up and
hopefully increase them with a few
volunteers and things like that for
those peak periods particularly during
the school holidays in July and August